[MUSIC PLAYING]
TYLER: All right.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name a Tyler,
alongside Urosh.
And today, we're going to be
talking about G Suite Meeting
Solutions.
Just a reminder, you
can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
I think one caveat
as we start is
this is going to a pretty
high-level introductory
overview to G Suite
Meeting Solutions.
So feel free to ask questions
if you'd like a deep dive,
or were happy to--
just shoot us a note,
and we can set up a
separate session for you.
All right.
So I guess to set the stage and
talk about context a little bit
as to why are we here, when
we talk to a lot of customers
today, we see that
they're really
having trouble communicate
across departments
and different teams.
If you think, more
and more folks
are working from different
cities or different countries.
It's getting increasingly
common for people
to work from home
once in a while.
Or even if you're
on a business trip,
it makes sense
that you want to be
able to connect with the rest of
your team and get things done,
not just be focused on the
travel part of the trip.
One interesting stat
is 50% of the workforce
may be working remotely
in some capacity
by 2020, according to
a Fast Company article.
And it's not just Google or
our customers who see this.
But if you survey
a broader group
of managers, or IT,
or different analysts,
they're seeing the same trends.
And a lot of folks are worried
one of the biggest obstacles
they face today is how do you
communicate across departments.
So how do you get
your marketing team
to talk to your product
team or to your sales team,
and are today's technologies and
tools keeping pace with that?
And so I'll go into our
detailed solutions in a minute,
but this is kind
of those problems
that lots companies
are facing, is
the approach we're trying
to take with G Suite.
How do we empower
teams and people
to do their most impactful work?
And so two principles we think
about with that are, one,
how can you make
things together?
So how can our tools help
you collaborate with others
but while not
sacrificing on speed.
How can you make things fast?
So your tools get out of the
way and help you collaborate
in a way you're used to.
Not inventing a
whole new process.
And so that's where our UCaaS,
or Unified Communication,
offerings come into play.
So I'll do a brief intro
on each of these in case
you're new to G Suite or you
haven't heard of these before.
But all of them--
our goal is to help
customers communicate
with colleagues-- customers
and partners-- from anywhere
to get things done.
So a brief intro.
Hangouts Meet in the top left.
That's our video
conferencing app.
So basically effective video
meetings from anywhere.
Hangouts Chat.
That's our team chat and direct
message tool and platform.
Google Voice we don't
go into as deep today,
but that's for telephony
and communicating
with other colleagues.
Urosh and I will talk a little
bit later about our hardware
offerings as well.
At the bottom there is
Hangouts Meet hardware.
So that's kind of dedicated
video conferencing equipment
to get a great room with
reliable sound and video.
And finally, Jamboard,
if you're interested
in digital whiteboarding.
How do people from
different locations
work together seamlessly?
So I'm going give you a brief
overview, talk about chat,
and then pass it over to Urosh.
But overall principles,
why you'd want
to use these kind of tools.
One is it can really transform
or change the way you work.
Before, for example,
if you needed,
for a project,
three review cycles,
you might be able to
cut that to one or two
if you're able to just
jump on a video conference
or solve something
over chat quickly.
Another is these tools are
actually deeply integrated
into G Suite.
So you're not having to
learn a whole new system.
These things work with your
existing Gmail or calendar,
or with your docs and
file storage, like Drive.
Thirdly, they're built
for the enterprise,
so for large customers.
Most of these
products are available
globally across a
bunch of countries.
We have really high standards
for security and reliability.
And then, finally, you can try
them at no additional cost,
right?
So they come with your
existing G Suite subscription.
So we think it's
really compelling
to help your teams
collaborate and communicate
in a different way.
So like I mentioned, I'm
going to go over briefly Chat.
So there's three components
we think about what Hangouts
Chat can offer for customers.
One is pretty self-explanatory--
direct messages.
So you can kind of ping
or message anybody just
to get a quick
answer to something.
But there's also
dedicated rooms.
You can think of them as
spaces for certain topics
or certain teams to communicate
and get things done.
And then, finally, thinking
about the bot platform,
integration.
So in addition to
chat, can you add
more functionality or
workflows and use cases
as you're kind of communicating
with others to get things done.
So here's a screenshot or
GIF of what chat looks like.
I'll do a brief walkthrough if
you haven't tried it before.
On the left-hand
side, that's where
you can see things organized
by either rooms or people.
So this is what a lot of our
customers-- kind of their home
base for the day every day,
where you can ping a person
to get an answer to something.
Or there's these specific
project or topic rooms.
So for example, there's
a marketing room
where you can discuss things
with the rest of the marketing
team.
Or you can jump into
Sales and Marketing Room
to get a broader set of people.
So that's kind of
how it's organized.
And the core content
what you're seeing
is just a deep
dive into one room.
It's called Marketing Room.
What's interesting about this
is it's organized by threads,
almost like you'd
be used to in Gmail.
So you can have within
one room separate topics,
so it's very easy to scan
different information
and find the answer--
what you need quickly.
I alluded to this
earlier, but there's also
a bot platform, which has some
really interesting integration.
So you can do more than
just chatting with people.
For example here, on
the left-hand side,
you can see how you
might, within chat, just
create a support
ticket and assign it
to somebody without needing
to open that app separately.
Similarly, chat's great
for sharing files.
So there's a box integration
so you can quickly
share your Q4 a roadmap
that was stored within box.
Or, finally, here's
an example where
if you want to jump
onto an audio conference
with RingCentral, you can
do so right within the chat
interface.
I mentioned this earlier, but
all these features in Chat
are globally available
at no additional cost.
So we're localized in
28 languages currently.
You can support up to 8,000
people in a chat room, which
is, I think, more than you
ever need, or else it might
get distracting.
There's kind of a
full-screen web experience,
but also dedicated apps for
Android, iOS, and even Mac
and Windows clients as well.
And Google's always been a
big believer in accessibility.
So we have screen reader support
across a range of platforms
today.
So I really feel like any
team can adopt this right when
they start implementing chat.
So that was a brief high-level
overview and Chat deep dive.
Now I'm going to pass it
over to Urosh to talk more
about actual meeting solutions.
UROSH PAJIC: Thanks, Tyler.
So we [INAUDIBLE]
like Hangout Chat,
which is our enterprise
collaboration tool.
Now let's talk about Meet,
which is our videoconferencing
solution for G Suite customers.
Couple of ideas that
Meet is built on
is that it's easy to join,
high-quality video and audio,
and you can join in from any
device, such as web browser,
meeting room, mobile app.
And it's rich with
features, and so on.
Meet launched in 2017.
And 2018, we made huge strides
to make it more enterprise
and to cover more use cases.
So some reasons why
you should consider
adopting Meet in
your organizations
are now we have even larger
meetings than before.
That means up to 100
full participants.
So anybody can speak.
Anybody can share and present.
And you can stream a meeting
up to 100,000 viewers.
And I'll go into more details
on each of these later on.
Second is interoperability.
So we know that a
lot of our customers
have existing VC
hardware in place,
and they don't want to give up
that investment if they should
switch to a new
meeting solution.
So that's where interoperability
between Meet and other
solutions comes into place.
And third is G
Suite integration.
So the biggest value of using
G tools with other G Suite
products that you already
have is business processes
that are built in
and flow seamlessly
from one application to another.
So, larger meetings.
I said 100 full
participants, which
is going to cover most of
your collaboration use cases.
If you have more than 100
people speaking in a meeting,
maybe you should
schedule an offsite.
But if you're looking to
connect with people from all
around the world, global
offices, schedule a town hall,
even stream a
conference, that's where
live streaming can help you.
It supports up 100,000 viewers
through our YouTube video
infrastructure but with
security and SLA off
the G Suite Enterprise SLA.
It's very easy to set up.
You don't need IT
to intervene here.
You just go to Calendar, your
schedule a normal meeting,
and you just turn on
a livestream for it.
It's as easy as that.
Then you have to
share the livestream
link with the attendees,
and that's it.
When it comes to
interoperability,
think about Cisco,
Polycom devices
that you see all around
your organization.
And then currently,
before, they would not
be able to join a Meet meeting.
That means that if you
want to standardize a meet,
you would have to
slowly replace those.
We're talking about thousands
of dollars in lost investment.
Now, with our
partnership with Pexip,
you can actually connect
all of these units,
including Skype for Business
as well, into a Meet meeting.
And that's not just good
for your organization.
It's also if you have third
party partners on Ciscos
and Polycoms and
Skype for Businesses,
they can join a Meet
meeting that you set up
through the same system
without even having to change
how they use this hardware.
And then integration
across G Suite.
So one thing as we
develop these tools--
we think about how do we
enable the whole lifecycle
of a meeting, not just
actually the conversation.
So how do you prepare,
how do you join a meeting,
how do you start, how do
you make it more effective.
So working together
with G Suite solutions,
we look at each of these areas.
So for preparing, for example.
Smart scheduling is
where we rely on Calendar
and on Hangouts Chat.
In Calendar, when you schedule,
you need to select a room.
But a lot of times, you don't
know the size of the room,
what kind of equipment
does it have,
what floor, how many
people does it sits.
So Calendar has these auto
suggestion capabilities
where we actually tell you
this is the closest room to you
or your room or you book.
This is for enough
people in that office.
So you don't have to really
think about these details.
Second one is Tyler
was talking about Chat.
So sometimes you want to chat
with people around something,
and then you realize that each
message is actually making
the situation more confusing.
So you want to escalate
into a video conference
because sometimes it's easier
to get to a conclusion now way.
So we have something
called Meet Bot,
and it's going to
help schedule a call,
find the right time
between everybody who
participates in this chat,
and put it on your calendar.
So you don't even
have to think and go
back between the
tools event schedule
and what's the
people's availability.
In terms of engagement
during a meeting,
if you used Meet before,
you had only one layout.
You could see the speaker, or
you could see the presentation.
That's something that
is going to change
beginning of next year,
where we are introducing
adaptive layouts.
The whole idea is that we know
what kind of meeting that is.
Is somebody presenting,
and who is presenting?
So we should show the
presentation and the speaker.
Is there a presentation
and multiple people
having a conversation?
Then we're going to show both
the deck and the people who
are talking.
If it's a bunch of you
in a room just sharing
a presentation of the screen,
we won't show any presenters
at all.
It's going to be just one
huge focus on a presentation.
So basically, we are using some
basic machine learning models
to make meetings more
effective and engaging.
In terms of
assistance, if you're
looking to use a
lot of our machine
learning and voice
commands that you
know with Assistant, but also
in the enterprise as well.
So for customers with
Hangouts need hardware,
we're introducing voice actions.
So, hey, Google,
start a meeting.
Or hey, Google, take notes.
Or hey, Google, book this
room for under 30 minutes
if it's free.
The second thing is
integration with Docs.
This transforms Docs from a
powerful document-editing tool
into the best meeting
note-taking tool.
So that's how you can track
your agenda, your action items,
and take notes.
This helps meeting
more productive
and get everybody start
the next meeting faster
and more efficient.
When it comes to
brainstorming, you probably
heard about Jamboard, which
is our award-winning digital
whiteboard.
It enables remote
teams to collaborate
on an unstructured content.
So drawing, getting an images,
really trying to be creative,
and really getting
to coming together
to bring new ideas
without having to travel,
and without having
to be in person.
Jamboard is completely connected
to your G Suite domain.
You can share.
You can continue.
You can send them.
You can actually explore
them and continue
on where you left off.
We also have mobile and tablet
applications for Jamboard,
so you're not limited to just
the actual physical device.
And all of these solutions
are built for enterprise.
I think it's very important
to emphasize that.
Even with the livestream
larger meetings, with Jamboard,
it completely adheres to
the Google G Suite SLA.
So two-factor authentication.
We control third party access
to meetings pretty strictly.
And if you do not invite third
party people to your meetings,
they're not going to
be able to access.
Or if you do not
allow access, they're
not going to be able
to be part of it.
Completely certified
for HIPAA, GDPR, ISO,
SOC, and other standards that
you would expect them to be.
So to summarize a
little bit, what
Tyler and I were talking about
is these tools are primarily--
the biggest value is that
they transform how you work.
They [INAUDIBLE] mundane
tasks from email,
or reduce time to join a
meeting, or make it easier
for people to collaborate.
And then they are deeply
integrated into G Suite,
so your business process or
day-to-day habits actually
are--
this becomes part of
your day-to-day habits
and makes it much
more streamlined
to collaborate together.
Built for enterprise.
The slide that I just mentioned.
So security compliance
and G Suite SLA.
And then, finally, these
are free to anybody
who's a G Suite customer.
So no additional cost.
And you don't need
to have any point
solutions that are going to
cover any of these use cases.
So how to start?
What's next?
We have a couple starter guides
for Hangouts Meet and Hangouts
Chat that you can check out.
And this is how you--
both for admins
and the end user.
So if the admin wants
to try out Meet or Chat
in their organization, how to
set it up, how to promote it.
Second thing is if you're
a user, and you have Meet
and Chat enabled, how to start,
and where to actually go,
and how to learn more about
using these solutions.
And then, if you need any
more deep dive on our hardware
offerings, on our
software offerings,
you can contact the
Meeting Pod at this email,
and they'll be happy to assist
you with further information.
And with that, stay tuned
for live Q&A. We will be back
in less than a minute.
TYLER: All right, welcome
back to Cloud OnAir.
We took a short
break, but now we
have some questions coming in.
So we're going to
answer these for you.
So I'll kind of moderate.
And I'll answer a few,
and pass some to Urosh.
So the first one.
What are the benefits of
an integrated video meeting
tool versus a standalone one?
Urosh, do you want
to speak to this?
UROSH PAJIC: Yeah,
it's a great question.
So, like I said before,
what we focused with Meet
is supporting the whole
lifecycle of a meeting.
So how you prepare, how you
engage, how do you follow up,
how do you make
meetings more effective.
And that's why the
integration of the G Suite
are very important.
Think about note taking,
scheduling meetings,
finding time, escalating
from Chat to Meet.
It's very important
that all of these things
save time on your
day-to-day basis.
With a standalone
solution, you actually
have to integrate that
standalone solution
into your existing ecosystem.
First of all, that's costly.
And it's actually never--
you're never able to do
it to the full extent
that you actually need it.
So standalone solution
can be costly,
or maybe they satisfy a
specific niche use case,
and that's why you keep them.
But the integrated
ones definitely
bring more value to the table.
TYLER: Cool, thanks.
The next two are related--
I think a little more
tactical as well.
I'll take the second one
but give you the first one.
So the first one is, how
many attendees does Hangouts
Meet support on a single call?
UROSH PAJIC: Right.
So, going back to the
slides from before,
100 full participants.
So people who can
actually join--
participate by
speaking or presenting.
And up to 100,000
viewers for a livestream.
So view-only mode.
TYLER: Right.
And, relatedly, how many
people can be in one chat
thread at one time?
I believe the number
currently at 8,000.
So, basically, you can
support really large teams
or, essentially, a
whole organization
communicating in one thread.
OK, the next question.
Is Hangouts Meet hardware
necessary necessary,
or can I just use
my laptop and phone?
That's a good question.
I'll take this one, but free
to add more color if you want.
So you can use Hangouts Meet
just on your laptop or phone.
It's free as a part of G Suite,
and it works pretty well.
Especially if you're taking
a one-on-one meeting,
a laptop can work.
Or on the go in an
airport, your phone
is a really useful client.
We found most customers,
especially larger ones,
really enjoy the dedicated
room hardware just
to have a room that's always
working and ready to go.
You also do get a little
bit higher quality of audio
and video-- in the visuals--
as it's dedicated
for that purpose.
Whereas your
smartphone or laptop
is trying to do a lot
of different things.
So we really encourage it
to help drive adoption,
and to have the highest
quality meetings possible.
Cool, next question.
Where can I learn
more about Jamboard?
A few things here.
One, the email address we
gave earlier in the slides,
Meeting Room Pod,
they'd be a great team
to shoot a note to if you
have specific questions.
But also you can just
Google the word Jamboard,
and we have a lot
of online resources
and websites to
help you learn more.
There was a related question.
Is Jamboard free with
a part of G Suite?
The answer to this
one's a bit twofold.
The dedicated hardware
is an additional cost,
but you can actually download
the mobile app or tablet
app for free.
So I'd encourage you
to try that, play
with it to see if you like
it and want to learn more.
Cool, next question.
Are there tools
or training for IT
to help with adoption of
Hangouts Meet and Chat?
Urosh, do you know
a little about that?
UROSH PAJIC: That's a good one.
So if you're refer to one
of the previous slides,
we do have some starter packs
on how to start with Meet
and how to start with Chat.
So they do focus
on the IT admin.
They're going to show you how
to enable it for your domain,
how to roll it out.
The best practice we've seen
is to probably roll it out
for a smaller subset
of your domain.
Maybe your IT organization.
Start adopting,
start integrating
with your third party systems.
And then roll it off from there.
TYLER: Got it.
That makes sense.
And last question.
Do these features also
apply to customers
of G Suite for Education?
I know this presentation
was more enterprise focused.
Urosh, what do you
think on that one?
UROSH PAJIC: It's
a good question.
So all of these features do
apply to G Suite for Education.
For example, for Meet, we do
have customers in education
that are streaming
classes live over Meet,
and that completely
transformed the way
they do online education.
Jamboard is something
that's being
used in education as well.
And then customers
who actually do
have a lot of internal
meetings on Meet, they actually
use Hangouts Meet hardware as
well for their meeting rooms.
TYLER: All right.
Well, thank you for
sending in your questions.
Really appreciate it.
That's all for today.
Please tune in, I believe, next
week for the next Cloud OnAir.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as